welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 64 it's another glorious
Sunday and we are back at the roundtable
on the Lord's Day and today the round
will rejoice we got part two of the e3
2018 prediction series and Sony is next
up to bat I'm extremely proud to have
all this Sony royalty at the roundtable
so let's get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who in my opinion is
one of the most naturally entertaining
youtubers in the game even though this
Lord has always been synonymous with the
PlayStation brands he is a true game at
heart in his indie spotlight and last
names always showcase his trademark ease
introducing the Sony Commissioner a
member of both the weapon wheel and
pressed our podcast the Lord of jiggy
food choices and the creator of the all
wheel abre movement fly from Montana
keen and making his debut into the realm
of the Lord's my man Lord Jack moves
Johnny how you doing sir oh man a
once-popular buddy is jack mummy it's
cool but you can also call me much-loved
man glad to have you it is a failure he
just did it off the rib that's love a
huge fan glad to get this poppet and of
course we have a lord who is no stranger
to the round table and teaches us all to
respect gaming this Lord always creates
a movie with everything he is involved
with exhibits infectious energy and will
always give his two cents for any gaming
topic introducing the host of the
counsel podcast and
online arcade movement the Lord who may
trigger you on Twitter yet continues to
keep all of duty and the fight game
genre alive live from the boogie with
the hoodie and make it his return to the
realm of the Lord my man no J Bari how
are you doing sir
yo yo yo what is good YouTube what's up
PlayStation nation it is your boy Jay
Bari and yo I gotta say this man I am
Lawrence podcast they got the best intro
ever make a yoke yeah I feel special
right I know when they introduce you you
will smile I feel flattered you got that
J bar eat eat oh yeah man it's gonna be
a movie we never got our intro Kratos
he's having some technical issues
hopefully you can get the Lord in here
of course you know we got the four
horsemen a gaming those usual suspects
at the round table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the howl of the young wolf
Lord addict how you doing sir doing
pretty good are you guys shut up the
Lord addict may put out of room yeah put
out a real emotional tweet that this
week that made me feel good man just you
know talking about the ILP history you
know salute you bro you know as far as
that whole thing you know our history
how we first started in the ILP with
just destiny stuff and I really
appreciate that tweet so
where's that it's nowhere has been
retconned before we got a deal we have
our gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives
for the single player selfish experience
and also the sastra Thomas
mr. offline profile Illuminati himself
mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir I'm
doing fantastic man I'm running on fumes
but you know that's that's always the
case on Sunday so I'm good I'm happy
PlayStation nation in the building cute
King got the gloves out I know cause we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
excess gamer oh the lord of combat
sports who was a man of his convictions
the man's nothing less than that premium
experience and is to get money game up
Oh be loving Lord King how you doing sir
I'm doing so good today and if you know
you've been following my Twitter you
understand the king woke up to a lot of
stuff being said he's looking for a lot
of dudes and they had to my man Kratos I
brought mini Hawk to take care of them
but it seem like he's stuck in traffic
or something I don't know what happened
from who's my man and all but you gotta
get in this room you know that
so people are anticipating this and it
seems a little bit disingenuous
jack-jack move Johnny gotta come in and
hold it down for you and barri gotta
hold it down and of course you know the
shinobi gaming ninja himself law Cognito
swear never illness in the realm of the
ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hit so let's
get into what the Lord's are playing
Lord Jack what games you've been playing
this week man oh man this week at home
uh what have I been playing this we got
played a little bit of South Park stick
of truth let them in on a piece for
South Park fractured but whole which is
the sequel platon that yesterday boy
plasmon out here I know I've been
playing them in a lot of games man a
plan a way out last week like oh yeah
what else
fire 13th they're playing that you I
love when you stream that like door very
stressful bro big update on the game so
let's play a little bit better man up
all I mean gaming on this week yeah yeah
Lord
J bar bar was playing this week dan I
gave is very is a stunning game man
right from the RIP you want to know what
that's a a triple a game when it comes
to PlayStation or blu-ray movie games
they are smooth
[Laughter]
well now also between RPG called austere
yeah great getting deep into that is
getting a lot better and yeah I'm loving
that game and loving that game now he's
playing a lot of believes Blue Cross tag
battle the trial version still
practicing in that until when the game
comes out that's generally on card of
course the course hold it down no you
say whatever you in plays her stay to do
Katie all day I see them streams going
out shad
Tim dog well yeah keep going yeah it
almost had like a heart attack I it's
been the first time we're like tethering
is annoying but it does have its
usefulness when like they're you they
spawn into like a game that you don't
have a the car that you have isn't like
a four-seater yes so like just someone
just [ __ ] out a lot but like will okay
kid like I was like coat coat me and
coat will drive to the to his base and
you just chill here cuz it's gonna
telling you to us anyway so we get to a
certain part in the map and kids getting
killed their kid it's tethered into a
Hornet on bees so I had like I had like
literally like a smoother of Hell so me
almost dying and keep in mind this is
permanent death I had to go out save kid
with no health the cheese's they come
back before I died no doubt Dana that's
a successful in Louis saw that what
you've been flavor
same thing state of decay to whenever I
get a chance Levin our here now offline
just profile
no invite went our way my xbox never
rings off yeah then on the switch I
picked up that blood-stained curse of
the moon yeah but not as old school as
really old school Castlevania that's
that was part of these stretch goals for
now that's that I wanted cuz they made
they met they stretch goal and I wanted
to know if it's a 16-bit or the eight
because it looks really really good it
looks better than 8-bit so it looks
cleaner like it the style is 8-bit but
it's obviously it's cleaned up so it's
not you're not gonna have you know the
pixelization like do you know the
flashing pixels like you had old-school
8-bit games so like the technical stuff
of 8-bit games has been kind of ironed
out but the look and style is definitely
8-bit and I mean as a stretch goal thing
that's like this other side thing that
inti creates did it it's not ego
Igarashi working on it alright it's
great man I mean it's old-school
Castlevania it is NES Castlevania done
great like down to the music like
everything is really good and then I
picked up the Mega Man Legacy Collection
I mean they do they do help you out like
well you know the old game we don't have
the reflexes we used to have so they
have like a rewind function you could
just yeah yeah I can't do that anymore I
can wear this weakness yo it's gonna
surprise the hell out of you but I've
been on that destiny so hard as Christ
and a woman got you yo it's got that old
feel back you're doing me go to Saint
Club you like lettuce girl man she about
their life like that like
the rain it was like oh it was just like
you know it was your imported tear to my
eye raining a lot we was doing an
escalation God was out there just
tossing Nova bombs and grabbing it was
just it I was like yo Chris
this is it right here escalation number
seven we shouldn't be able to do like a
dependent Franco were random blueberries
it's to get behind mix it gives you that
whole what destiny was supposed supposed
about legs and I love when you see a
dude jump in and he throws an over balm
and you look at him and you check them
in he's to army 385 like we got a shot
yeah
God is in the building I really like
what they're doing on Mars and I've been
trying to peel myself away from that
game um to play state of decay to
because I'm really slacking in that no
rush no rush
an arrest that's true is no rush because
you know multiplayer games let me bring
the engagement numbers million hours a
week you know
[Music]
we got this hotel play too much this
week but I brought a switch with me
still rocking at home what you call that
better saga getting a little better with
it liking that earlier this week did
play like King said the deci to iron
banner was rocking with that no
escalation protocol and staining the K I
want a shout out some lords man shouting
lawson aldo in the chat
yo don't drive with that man that man
does not know how to drive car made a
run medicine food stuff for the base I'm
mighty I could use this but my game got
to get back to the base this bear
flipped the car it girls about to be on
fire we rushing out the back of the
truck try to get the goods out before it
explodes out the Loire Valley con Baraka
with him as well and I just really like
the gameplay Luke you know really
rewards you helping out a friend in
there gameplay session and all that you
don't say it's so long we gonna get into
these topics got allowed to talk about
it obviously this is the e3 2018
prediction series for Sony and there's a
lot going on a PlayStation nation
obviously we have the state of the ps4
we're heading into 2018 going on you
mean there's four things going on so um
yeah pretty much you know you know the
dominance of God of War the sales 5
million you know the first month 3.1 in
3 days obviously again be a contender
the resurgence of the single-player
games like Harrah's zero dawn Detroit
and first party arty eyepiece so I want
to bring us off to the art guests
obviously Lord Jack I just want to give
a shout out that do beat that on the
hardest difficulty all solo
war is not like I don't want that smoke
not that I'll probably do that now not
the first place
[Laughter]
obviously weak like I said there's been
a lot of momentum heading into an EP
2018 for Sony so it's not a lot Jack
move you know what's what you're feeling
on the state of the ps4 coming into e3
you know with it with the single-player
stuff and just overall what you're
feeling about Sony right now
Oh feeling very positive about Sony
actually man like you say you know
coming off God war uh personally if not
my favorite franchise you know where
pretty much my favorite French up to
stuff like that but uh great game great
sales positive reception they just
launched Detroit what was that yesterday
they pull yesterday so you know it's
real positive um they got some new
titles on the horizon uh they gonna be
showing so I'm feeling good about it I
don't think they trying to you know they
pretty much in the driver seat right now
control Chile yeah Loki Loki I don't
really have to do too much else like as
far as I'm concerned as far as the first
part is concerned for a risk I mean you
know they get spider-man coming this
year but uh I think they also fall back
stuff right now you know what I mean
like say sorry that's what that's why
I'm feeling like yeah Lord
Bari let's get into it man I stated a
ps4 heading in the e3 how you feeling
right now
oh I'm agree with Jack I'm feeling good
honestly you know you know when you just
wake up in the morning you know you're
gonna have a good day you wake up every
morning you're in a good mood because
PlayStation got the game no it's not
even that is they pumping up these wack
numbers Oh
and wag number right I heard the wagon
um but their God walk triple a right
triple a title right tens across the
board right he did five million right
you did five right that five was good
for you felt good for you we did that
with pub preview yeah what's the
engagement on our pub jido so you felt
good about a complete finished game that
got tens and our broken game that's in
preview too did the same numbers why are
you feeling good get a burn me come on
right now seconds here listen the second
tier game is doing the same numbers that
show number one tear game the third do
this in the back of our bus raised his
hand and said I got them look at the end
of the game it took how long for pub G
to do that numbers it took three days
move on that's not evil failed them with
you bring it up you bringing up the what
if you have nothing concrete
you want me to shoot you dead link do
you want me to charity I guarantee if
not the only concrete failed numbers you
have before the PC if not for no Xbox
then we going up into 20 million polish
game to a very polished game guys
consider me the game of the year you
know what your game will be considered
game of the year and that's not that's
not a lot I can concede to that I can
concede that you got tens but what I was
talking about is the fact that you was
beating your chest with the same that
was a guy with a broken game you beat
your chest with a strong hand this is
you you beating your chest with the
strong hand and I had to get him beaten
the same saying take the same shower you
taking that smelling roses because they
told you you know what happens is we got
the probably the economy size was you
probably got the big put a clock on your
head they say you join your run is over
came out and say oh call that king and
then we can go back to close close
please
[Laughter]
[Music]
all I was built up from cradles I think
I think the attitude of PlayStation is
very high you know there's a lot of
games that people are anticipating going
into e3 I know they're gonna be focusing
on the four games but look at those four
games those are huge
games that they're focusing on man you
know anything else outside of that is
after you know the cherry on the top
with those games but look last of us
who's not anticipating that game here
you know that's the see look Ashima yes
that's train if it's good then eight
that's another caveat you know I mean
absolutely absolutely so let's get Lord
addict in here what do you feel about
our sony coming into III their position
not going in like how you feeling about
me
like the past year and a half like they
don't have to do anything like I Jack
said about me I think it's even a little
bit more than that it's just like
if they don't have it on first party
they have really close relations to have
it on second so they they look at
persona that's probably one of the
arguably the best gains that's been on
the ps4 to a lot of people and that's I
even buy their studio because they have
such a great relationship with that
studio it's pretty much their studio
absolutely how you feeling about the
state of PlayStation nation heading in
the e3 man I think you look at it
they're definitely in cruise control but
I mean they've showed the past two years
like Alex said like they don't they
don't take the boot off the neck and
it's like they're really reactive like
the first two years of PlayStation they
pretty much got away without releasing
any super big first party games they got
away with it doing and then everything
there was a rush of everything now and
then since that happened they'd taken
every opportunity when Xbox you know you
know has a little big update right there
to stomp on it I think whatever it is
they they react in some way shape or
form I don't think they're going into
III laxa days ago I think they're gonna
show those big for games like Baris said
those were huge games that people want
to see some that we haven't seen
gameplay for we're gonna see gameplay
for so that that should be exciting in
and of itself I just don't see them not
dropping something that we don't expect
are they gonna do it regardless is that
gonna be like having our third party I
think they're gonna open card I really
do I think they're gonna give it to open
a close we don't um I would say bar you
had somebody jump in on it yeah you know
the PlayStation is less like it's a
constant barrage of games we're getting
you know like he's dodging games
wasting right you're not busy playing
games yeah you you have so much to
choose from to play when it comes of
PlayStation not only that you can do
that currently well in the future you
know what's to come
yeah so based on based on that roadmap
what you say a bar like you could get to
see no way coming you already busy in
the car or you playing on and then in
the future you're gonna be busy as well
because there's games coming there's a
lot of Shamir I'm in but I think I think
it specially for e3 I think especially
for e3 they realize the power of that
you know that wow moment regardless to
when that game is coming out they've
seen it before like you know they now in
Shenmue and Shenmue who knows when
that's coming you know same thing with
that strain like things like that they
know the power of that announcement and
that moment regardless of when that game
is coming so that's to meet it they're
still gonna drop some bombs you know
maybe six years out playstation five
games like whatever like maybe one or
two no I'm sure they have plenty of
things in the pipeline they're not ready
to talk about yet I don't want to hold
off on right I think at least one or two
okay that we're not expecting Lord King
how do you feel about the PlayStation
coming in it was like he gave you his
all and it was everything was beautiful
he did super moves he did all that and
he was still standing there you just
looked at him and said you know you look
at him you like now you're solved
because once you found out the pattern
to do like it really ended for you and
the match is folded very quickly right
and then I've noticed something I've
noticed it like like like Jason
everybody got this up of essence and not
knowing that we got the the ar-15 right
across the street aimed at your dome
infrared beam right little window and
fly
but you already know your demise is
already in order for this over get your
boss told you it's a rat like you talk
about the canary what my thoughts on the
PlayStation going in they coming in on a
high like that got a wall it was fire
Detroit imma buy it with super steel I'm
gonna get that um I got a lot of games
like the Sun I like he said pass under
which is true though the RPGs and the
needs and then these games they had a
lot of bustle of games that had you
moving and I could feel why you got a
pep in your step as zipping you spit I
feel it I understand it I get it but
what I'm saying is the tortoise in the
head at the end of the show I was really
gonna go Willie anticipate in the Xbox
show because you already know what's
happening in your show your show was
already played shut up a let go he said
fellas go in Sony with the rest of the
cracking body and Sony's shaking in me
reason why I'm really watching the Xbox
show because I want to see that I want
to see the disaster we go into this show
we don't really know what your show is
so we can like miss it and hear about it
right so the Nintendo directs we know
that they're gonna put a name of a game
up and everybody gonna go crazy but
Microsoft show is the most anticipated
show that is true I was like console
with a king this man because you feel
like you really got the pep in your step
I don't know how
you know what you know why you know why
I got my step because I told you and I
just gave you off for instance right
like just did your trihard game your
best you shot your best dog that's the
god of War's your best dart for Cognito
numbers was they shot the best dart our
game is in preview I would say let's
break it down like real talk like let's
break it down
I don't remember solve help me out on
this when when the up G and now when a
20 they hit that that opposite the 5
million I don't recall it because got a
war base he was three million like what
two A's I mean it's more now is two
million right please hey you put in like
well but we gotta be real as far as
what's impressive the fact that let's be
real you know
even Lord failure man you only be going
impressive is the fact that let's be
real the narrative has been
single-player games or dying that there
and the fact that let's be real like pub
G is a multiplayer game that creates
that engagement the engagement numbers
will always be there like what they're
talking about when they say that that
genre is dead
they're talking about you know the ones
and duns and then you got some people
that will try harder to keep playing the
games to get the Platinum's and the
stuff like that which is cool there is
no ass
to this you know like for its it's great
when it's there and that's coming from a
boardroom that doesn't reflect how we
feel right that right we love I don't
care like you don't get what happens to
the game after we play we are selfish in
that whole thing like we don't care if
it come on if it gives the ball DLC
bring it on sir I'll take that yeah
what if there's encapsulated in that one
special moment we're not looking at the
boardroom numbers we're not trying to
run a company we just want to play a
game right so I feel where they come
from when they say it's dead as far as
those numbers go but in our minds the
single-player experience isn't dead
because we look forward to these games
like spider absolute let me jump in
because at the end of day like we have
to be real to is like I have one point
door single play it was kind of on a
decline like you know what you have to
call the dude is you got all these big
games and I'm you know destinies and all
that stuff that as far as even though
people may not like him from compared to
a single-player game kind of epic
experience we can't deny the sales you
know dominance that those games are
having and it feels like Sony has kind
of bucked that trend right like Sony has
it doing something that's kind of like
want to be honest with you I do think
Sony helped but I think Zelda is the one
that absolutely Zelda proved a lot of
things like when Zoda came out it proved
that multiplayer that single-player
wasn't dead absolutely so it's like it's
one of those things that about the lady
at your table is up Uncle Phil they go
at it or they go in or I want you to put
up who you want to be president until
you can figure out who you want to be
President Lee Phil the hell alone
well we got to remember about all the
single-player sales stuff versus
engagement right all that narrative
around single-player dying you came
from all of these companies they didn't
come from the players right it income it
came from these companies it came from
the companies that realized that and
relative to what these other games were
making these games with loot boxes these
games that are living games that are
pulling in you know hundreds of millions
of dollars a month they're like wait a
minute
relative to that yeah it doesn't make
any sense to make a single-player game
single-player games are still making
money obviously as you can see we got
war um as anything that's come out on
Sony you can see they they're profitable
they're just relative to these other
things that that make you money
hand-over-fist
so they tried to create that narrative
to get people to focus to play more
fortnight to buy some more dresses and
you know in battle for it and you know
the thing about it is the gamers
themselves as we know those games are
not going anywhere
they're gonna find they're gonna find
figure out ways to monetize them for you
like you know that's what Phil's been
saying from the from the jump he was
like well it's more challenging to make
it now because of the environment that
we're in meaning they're not gonna make
as much money as other people want it to
make so how do you how to monetize that
right how you make it episodic or
whatever they plan to do but that's just
that's what it is
that's all it is I'll jump in right by
your side and we move what's that next
point yeah I mean I'm in the same boat I
think it's just they've they're in a
great position I mean it's definitely
like Lord Jackman was saying kind of
like cruise control you know they've
already kind of set up kind of we're
gonna do one can attack with the next
topic but um I think I think they ought
to be commended for blocking the trend
with single-player I think that's really
important I think that people that the
community has shown they are gonna
willing in fact if it's a quality
experience like a God of War Harrah's
they were going Detroit whatever people
gonna spend that money and that's good
to see because the market was kind of
shifted into an only multiplayer or MMO
active user kind of thing
and I'm saying so it's just to see what
happens you know saying what they got so
we don't move on to the next point and
it's about keeping the boot on the neck
what if anything does playstation needs
to improve and my question is like was
it a mistake revealing the e3 came so
early let's get out let's get jacking
this first we get boring up Jack do you
think how do you feel about that like as
far as improvement and on anything in
reference to
like the fact that we kind of got to e3
roadmap from Sony already Oh improvement
I might to think on that I'm sure some
stuff I would like for them to prove
honestly I can't think in well besides
fat I would like PlayStation now I would
like to be able to download the games on
PlayStation now I think that that will
be there will be a huge announcement of
course people on PSN name changes you
know a name myself some crazy back in
the day plans too early because these
are games you know people knew about you
know we know they're coming so it's only
you know it's only safe to assume that
they was gonna show these games again
you know to me lot of these guys Wayne
same gameplay we've never seen go such a
shame you know I'm not sure about it I
gotta see that game we seen spider-man
spider-man is coming out in what four
months so of course they don't show that
Lance was part two we've never really
seen that game so of course they're
gonna [ __ ] like you know animes
common-sense stuff so Hayden announced
it to air is pretty much if you were you
know if you have what they call sent you
wouldn't know there's you know hop off
the porch like damn why Yelena Nelson
for cloud like come on man y'all know
what's coming up you know where we get
us you that's what we gonna do Leslie
good DUSU you're just chilling right now
like you got your feet up
I'm pretty sure the last of us going up
to the ps4 they were pretty comfortable
too so I think you know at the end of
the day they date they've worked for
what they've done like it you know
regardless it's not an excuse you know
the switch of leadership the direction
that Microsoft randomly 182 like it's
showing and it's gonna cost them it's
gonna cost them bit I don't think it's
anything gonna cost them this generation
it's gonna cost them next generation too
but you being as far as course what cost
in what next generation it's gonna cost
Xbox it's gonna be more time oh because
they're behind hey you can't go into
next generation with the games that we
have now and expect people just to go
out and buy an Xbox or two or whatever
it's gonna be called like absolutely
like it's gonna it's gonna cost them
next generation - like people say
casuals is the most important market the
casuals are once the establish the
generation has already been established
at the beginning her who do you think
averts casual people go out and buy it
they're hardcore friends and if
everyone's playing on PS 5 guess what's
gonna happen the point apparently
everybody is playing on ps4 sales
figures that's out there yeah got like
90 million what's them engagement
numbers the silly part about all that
stuff is you beating your chest off for
five million but that's not even a
fraction of your base yeah but we've
already discussed no no I know I'm just
saying the five million number is
exclusive PlayStation did give out
engagement numbers right an Xbox
earnest report they told you about you
know how many people got Plus
subscribers how you grew how many games
online what about what about the keep
Naboo on the neck and as far as on is it
was it a mistake in your opinion for
them to reveal kind of those III pants
early I so I'm gonna do that the arm
improvement stuff where our legacy
absolutely I feel like when it comes to
policies nice an additional realm of
things I think Microsoft does have a leg
up on PlayStation where they actually
have official policies for like refunds
and you can you know gifting that the
best compliment as well now like station
do that especially with somebody myself
that is all digital they don't before
sometimes but it's not officially that
means it's case-by-case and also also
when it comes to like the trophies for
those of you that you know trophy I
would like to see something more like
social when it comes to that like you
know like how many you know gold
trophies or so much over this person got
in a week or month Phenom II I think
I'll be a little bit more engaging
instead of just looking at this trophy
was rare or this show food was super you
know very honest with you I be I be
straight up a little jelly over the
platinum [ __ ] like I would like Xbox to
have like a number of how many
achievements everyone's hundred
percentage but there's nothing like that
right the social engagements that far is
how many thing that does is tell me that
Randle Thor's beat me every month the
gamer score I don't Jack is gonna be in
the top for me it would be cool that's
like compare you know instead of like
you're comparing on Playstations it's
like it's only one per
you know I mean so mm-hmm I think I'll
be cool for like people that do you know
chase trophies and stuff like that you
it is just like a competitive edge or
you can just engage with people when it
with that no doubt I'm sorry we can take
a cookie Barker cut your bar the boot on
the neck
yeah the was already on the neck but now
right there if you want a Playstation
you're not you're not dissatisfied with
a product that you just brought because
like I said once you buy it you have so
many options to choose from it is not
only just the PlayStation that they
taken care of you had the VR aspect as
well
games upon case in there as we say she
bye-bye it's a VR you're gonna be
satisfied that could there's a lot of
games that you can choose from you know
I mean I just felt like the the the
attitude when it comes to the two
different fan bases we comparing Xbox
and PlayStation Nintendo the guys you
guys are on you guys are off the hook
this industry when it comes to the two
fan bases let's look at the differences
of what how people is going into e3
right PlayStation fans who's gonna eat
three with it like you know my man Jack
so we gotta we gotta you know if you
feel the mentality is different like you
because you feel like the Xbox play base
is kind of like on edge this is a makeup
whereas the Sony that works it's like
comfortable okay worried worried you
know like there's a lot of stances have
been changed here
- no Xbox and Playstation right where
before we don't want to show gains you
know that's oh that's the faraway no
it's like you know we got what you're
saying like like y'all guys like one day
you're thriving the next day it's almost
over fellas like they told you to wrap
it up B is winding down like your fun
days is almost over after spider-man
what up my man like it's really starting
to distill in his clothes yeah good
question in reference to that because I
know you brought that up before so do
you think because you know sony has
outright come out and said this is the
end of this generation for them like do
you feel that's a mistake as far as like
hubris is cutting off to generation too
early because behind it's like the
question is in a dominant position and
they really could explain the generation
if let me tell you something that I like
where this new president that he got
over there is going I like what he's
doing like they have to get a real
strategy cuz they do that they had
before the real strategies he was just a
boastful dude that was on Twitter all
the times like the new president right
so this dude is of real strategist in
the form of ok everybody was having
questions about going into III what the
PlayStation will be in what games are we
looking forward to he said put it all
out there we're in a position of win and
put it all out there so that takes away
all anticipation of anything so anything
that we do show is a plus just like bar
we just said we know what's coming
anything that comes after that is a plus
right is cherries on top right Jack move
right now Indy didn't do so you what he
did was it was so it took the pressure
off and put the pressure on Microsoft
when Microsoft told you this is going to
be a three-hour show a two-hour show
this is going to be the biggest we had
to move to another hall
this is how big it's going to be so that
noise was becoming deafening to the
point that he said all right we're not
even gonna compete we're gonna remove
myself out the battle and let them
compete with a self mm what snooty chick
is smart
got it shut it now shout the PC game
he's kind of like echoing what you're
saying okay he's saying Microsoft are
concerned about how many consoles they
move because they see it now is another
platform to put their services and
software on so we feeling like that's
the spaces both are in coming in you
know as far as you are you in agreement
with that King no no I'm in agreement
with all of that see what they're two
different companies like I just had to
point out to Jess the other day because
Jess was really upset with certain
things the Microsoft put out a racing
game that's on the Windows Store yeah
it's a touch game no it's not all man
you gotta say four days before then they
gave you the information on the
multi-purpose controller that will help
the handicapped right so you got to look
at it in this space they told you
anybody that wants to license this
technology we don't we won't charge you
a fee we will give it to you for free
dad got swept away you know there it was
one day of good news and that got swept
away that's big in the sense that that
gives engagement to other people well
Microsoft is trying to do is trying to
get other pieces then they're not in one
space everybody will love for them to
just be Xbox they're not in just Xbox
one base so Sony is in just Sony space
that TV division did the camera division
holding are you uh are you uh Microsoft
fan or you know the light mechs are you
are you like Xbox you know like I feel
like you have evolved your fandom I can
give you this Jay is this when my
company
says to me because you can't do this
when my company says to me go on your PC
and go play when you go abroad because
you don't have to lug your big system
with you when you go and you play the
same game and you can come back and you
can jump back on your xbox and all that
stuff that you played over there and you
can play over here mmm when they do that
and they said we're not charging you
anything because this is our ecosystem
you can't do that now Jack moved just
for the saying he wants something very
minor a name change they're holding you
hostage by your name all a remote plays
there before way before Microsoft been
doing I feel you I feel you remote play
remote play mmm was it really good for
you yeah I mean this is what I'll give
you right now
i'ma tell to you with Jack moons own
statement Jack moves own statement was I
wish we had something at a myself has
like downloading our games from
PlayStation now into our system right
Jack move indeed indeed so when you go
to game past and you download joke game
into your system that's what she was
looking for right didn't do that for you
and my president has is based on bias so
when you say going into this e3 I am
anticipating Sony to keep the boot on
the neck and the man of day doing I like
this new president this new president is
moving in a strategic fashion that he's
allowing this to happen and he's
countering very strict can I have a
question
how long you know I've said from the
start I think this year is the first
year that I'm really going if this III
happens in Microsoft unannounced
anything really decent this is the first
jungle be like yeah so supposed to look
a little shady is how long of a time
fashion needs to go by before we start
before we stop saying this strategic and
it's just the whole Indian vibrate
question the entire show when do I give
up with the with the BS what you say in
the face and tweet at Phil like what the
f Phil talking about because I'm going
this year I'm gonna get that interview
with Phil all right and I'm gonna have
at least two questions that I'm gonna
take from you guys and I'm going to ask
this guy dis questions right and I'm
gonna I don't care how wild it is you
can't do is not really an experience
because everybody can experience it's
not offensive it's not exclusive
all right so I'm gonna be at this
exclusive party to get the guy who
rubbed shoulders with the people that
should be talking about the people that
you talkin about you looking at you
followin I'm rubbing shoulders with them
I'm asking questions that you want me to
ask them I already met the people that I
president you ask so many questions
so why you can't change your name
got a war t-shirt and I asked him like
when I got a war t-shirt dude alright
but nah listen um going and I think the
boot will stay on the neck I think for
the foreseeable future until the last of
us comes out on PlayStation will be the
dominant system and it should be the
dominant system they work hard they
clawed back from the fiasco that was the
PlayStation 3 and they learned a lesson
they gave you exactly what she was
looking for they gave you a dominant
system moving forward and he kept
changing the field goal so we weren't
able to hit it now I'm gonna feel this
on that throat though don't put your
feet up don't get comfortable because
he's gonna kick that cheerful XP we
don't debate this is a Saudi already
know what your show is about we just
only topics I want to get you impression
on like we just want to finish out the
topic which is far as like what do we
feel place needs to improve evening III
and then as far as the do we feel it's a
mistake but I'm gonna reveal those
planes so early what's your feeling on
it I think they're kind of the kind of
cushion the backlash they would get if
they only show enough we do about right
kind of expectation check so I think you
know those four games are they're big
that those games are gonna close out the
generation for PlayStation 4 yeah you
know they gotta put emphasis on I mean
those guys got big budgets you know they
want to make everybody see what they're
working on and we want to see more of it
as well we haven't seen much of that
stranding or you know go Tsushima you
know so that's also interesting games I
mean absolutely whether they talk about
it
early or late that's they're gonna be
their focus so you might as well put
everything on Front Street and you know
let the fans know was one of them yeah
before full transparency so to speak
right regardless to work because
regardless to what if they go into that
if they're gone into that show without
them people know they were gonna focus
on those four games right and people are
sitting in the in the auditorium and
they fill out the IKEA furniture how
good those games are no matter how good
they show up they only show those four
games the PS nation will be in an uproar
because they weren't aware of this
because what you saying because you know
even last year like the PlayStation
Conference was a little bit different
you know people were they got kind of
feeling like the dead bodies hanging
from the ceiling and what actually that
was that was PSX I don't know if that
was the if that was a III if that was
PSX but you know they got a little weird
with it some people like the whole sit
down thing when they're talking to Cory
bar log and sometimes people don't use
my announcement announcement
announcement right I remember Bari
saying he didn't like it you want
announcements you want trailers you want
see the new stuff I hate like I hate
when both do this but I hate when they
take something like okay like maybe
Microsoft has a little bit more of a
room to not do it because they don't
have their own event like PSX but it's
like look man like why is it days gone
in this thing that games coming up
before anything else id3 we can't go
there like yes they got a whole month
preview right and then but coming out of
Judges week coming out of Judges week
sorry to start a coach coming out of
Judges week the word on days gone is not
great you got a home off preview right
that was the most fun III right
but who would be shown again at easy
people oh my god it doesn't matter if
they got that month I think it was a
mistake to do that month this is the
question let me get jacking this because
that is a great question when AG as far
as days gone and it was it on that list
right correct me if I'm wrong I like it
wasn't what what do you feel about the
whole day's going thing the omission and
do you feel like it's being mistreated
or what would your whole feeling about
the game itself uh i reaiiy would
probably say it was being mistreated but
then again I saw the footage I wasn't it
like you know they saying is alpha which
all right I gave it a pass on it it's
other things with the game that I'm not
feel it's like the issue with the games
is in the core it's not like the
aesthetics of the game these polish and
aneisa find an identity it is twice
similar it's too similar to the last of
us and it's and in systems it seems like
it's kind of similar to the state of the
case just drop out or do you want them
to just pull it back and fix it up and
then release it
mm-hmm what turns you off from it like
what's this things about that you know
feelin on me as far as the game well I'm
not really too tripping off the game
play cuz like they say SDR early you
know they developing it but uh it's like
little nitpicks I get with the game like
I said on a way to crafting menu look I
don't like that the main character his
voice actor I'm not too fond of that
running animation that definitely looks
but the game I'm not going I had an
issue with its supposed to be a zombie
game correct right how is it the student
explodes a bike and there ain't no
zombies coming around well the way they
look like the Haitian zombies
differently like almost like already
kind of used them against the AI as well
but if you're if you're I make
any kind of game in a zombie environment
how is it that a double a game like
state of decay has more per has more
consequences than making all this noise
then a triple a title game like days
gone exploding a bike oh my god they're
not treating it like it's a trip Oleg's
I get a treatment is different I would
treat it to me like it's a double a
title I'm not saying the quality doesn't
shine exact move said like all these
little nitpicks
lead up to you feeling blah about the
game right it's like it's a number of
little things that act they just add up
to you not feeling great about the game
can't really pin it because it falls
into the Sony mold perfectly let me
point out something in the chair okay in
people like dissecting what a triple a
double a is sing away tidal waves
how so you mean to tell me it's like a
double leg plus plus look I don't get
that in the previews a specifically said
this is the true play open-world game
they would get if they show days gone
again on e3 stage again that's not my
issue my issue isn't that it's not being
on there my issue it's it's they did the
whole thing wrong how are you gonna use
something like days gone which looks
like a good game up and so what we saw
mmm it's just like look like it
shouldn't have been showed on my game
informer this game should have been
shown actually had three I'm actually
I'm actually happy with showing a game
in Formica now you can get a dialogue
going back and forth as far as what you
see III you're not gonna get 20 minutes
the thing morning minute gameplay here's
like game but I think I think it would
have served the game better after e3 you
you give that new footage to e3 people
get to see it see what it is and then
the following month Game Informer comes
out with any more
besides Detroit that could have been put
on stuff like this and stuff like the
movement they're moving that's what I'm
starting to see them stumble because
it's like this is a game that you bet
that's been announced for a while this
is a game that people have been hyping I
was even like they you know I sure I've
made a couple statements like stay DK go
put the boot on at the end of the day
this is one of their games I wouldn't
say it's like like a pillar right but
you know people always give Sony credit
for quality they have great quality
games right but it's looking like
they're missed stepping with this game
like never giving this game that the
Charlotte reserves they're not giving
this why is it informer like how is than
a game coming out probably at the
beginning in that here this interested a
game called last of us to which you know
that deserves to be at e3 when that
games not coming out before days gone
how are these games that are not coming
out before days gone getting more shine
than the game coming out before then for
us yeah I'm gonna let me jump before
we're gonna see that's training the The
Last of Us - all that shit's being at e3
again next year we're gonna see I mean
listen my take on before we move on to
the main event topic it's just like it
is weird how it's being handled um I do
see what Baris sandor as far as to
triple-a you know them actually coming
out front and saying and it's going to
be you know that um we're gonna see you
know I actually it's funny cuz I miss it
today you guys saying like hey it
doesn't look polished and that's not
feeling it and I remember like a degrees
at e3
like I was kind of like digging it you
know so it was just an interesting take
on zombies to me it wasn't like oh my
god I've never seen it I'm not saying
I'm not feeling it I'm gonna finish
certain things that I'm gonna be
critiquing it about absolutely like one
thing I don't I never was a cyber filter
do because I hate
I'll call it the saggy that's something
that you want to see every time you play
the game you you constant gonna see this
guy running on the flight come on you
got you got double you gotta do better
than this you know I mean but like I
don't I don't agree with the whole shown
in the e3 I just saying like yo this
this how many tons of footage that we
got for this game I feel like they did
this way Game Informer just to get
people's opinion out there and then
that's why this game got pushed back
because I'm pretty sure this game was
gonna come out this year they already
saved it they say the game is done you
can play from the beginning to end and
now they just doing this day mm-hmm at
the end of the day the fact that they're
moving days gone like this I wouldn't
expect much mmm Microsoft does the same
thing when a game they know isn't going
to wow you crack that well no no they
put all kinds of effort behind crack
down I'm talking about not crack down on
about to see if these right talking
about it when I don't want a publisher
and a developer like they're doing now
is kind of taking cuz let's be real here
it's not it's in game informer
but the spotlight is e3 and when they
take a game out of the spotlight don't
expect much I mean it don't necessarily
mean it's not gonna be a III is it's not
having a deep dive I'm talking about
their conference not like the floor
itself how many how many times have been
on the conference though like it didn't
catch the spark it doesn't catch that
spark and start that fire yeah sauna
you'll put it on a burn and let it
simmer for a little bit and try to fix
little things to get those tickets now
what you might you might see it might
have a bigger presence at a PSX but even
PSX like a game that you're trying to
push for the beginning of next year
it should have been a III hear what you
say maybe just not getting the feedback
today so let's move on you say we got
the main topic we got that drop the mic
[Music]
[Music]
drop
what do Sony have to do it just kill gay
at that conference I mean I feel like
the segment is gonna the conference is
gonna be killed already with that last
node all gonna come out there and
they're gonna do what they got to do it
I'm pretty sure that's gonna be the talk
of e3 when it comes to quality mm-hmm
when it comes to this you know impactful
miss you know I mean you know the
story's gone
I feel like though for games that are
gonna show are like some of the biggest
games to come out this year or next year
I'm oppression a piratical I mean I'm
pressure bar like which ones
specifically that's it game over that's
what I know me personally is gonna post
well well spider-man we already know
it's coming but that's coming this year
we already seen spider-man what's gonna
offer if they show like a new villain or
something that's gonna set people off
that like you are like spider-man fan
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be off you know
I'm gonna be on Twitter praising and
dance and all that but I do feel that
the Last of Us to definitely be that
nail in the coffin like you'll just wrap
it up flat screen sorry do you see what
the president did
dopamine they told you it's almost over
this is what you got Gilligan there's no
expectations and the bomb I'm speaking
of the things that we know of the
platform the platform you prefer it is
nothing bigger than what I'm talking
about
to you this barri I can guarantee you
this I can guarantee you one thing that
will shut your whole presentation down
that will make y'all dudes in the
background go scrambling I can guarantee
you one fact if they come out there with
Halo Xbox X footage you're done son
in the building I'm giving you safe sex
this is gonna happen here old man
I told you you got four that's it last
the last three months inside Xbox has
got me I'm not anticipating anything
because we got hyped up will feel some
tweets on my yellow and gear is gonna be
there it is specify what halo and look
what you got no a lot of people just
watching this Xbox conference they're
going in there with very low
expectations people going with
Playstation conference they go in there
anticipating where they gonna show and
you're there's gonna be surprises there
the next petition ain't load like
surprises boring
what if is just to the script and it's
no surprise just to the script like
right now you just given me you told me
don't go into my conference with hope
they gave you what they told you they
told you full and done son you listen
you got the Fantastic Four that you
running in their way right we all know
how that movie ended now right let's say
there's nothing special no frills not
nothing else are you satisfied with
there is no what if they told you
gameplay from any of those games exactly
so that's all I mean that's gonna be
closest special right you know you know
that's coming
you know that stuff they're not gonna
talk they're not gonna say they're doing
deep dives in these games and not show
you gameplay you know that's coming
right
right now he's Boris I want okay right
so Mike I want to dry completely over
here and I'm like I said I'm not doing
what at the end of the day it is
possible where halo gets announced right
like I feel like right now
Sony has and now like they have neither
released the games if they've announced
or they're on the horizon
besides those four games so besides
those four games
what could something else be it's like
you guys always go out Microsoft because
all their studios have made or making
something the Halo gears and Forza and
then a you know the the playground it's
like what can they announce or or do we
have to wait I like a PSX anticipating
like that I I think is gonna be
announcer now I hope it's being
announces you know 20 in 2015 we got
probably one of the best games this
generation and I feel like it's due for
a sequel to come out where we get like a
blood-borne you would understand the
setup like I said I know
then I go into like my my my what a from
our prediction system okay go over I
thought you said you don't do what you
want reality no anything that I want
PlayStation do especially guys is its
salute fire in this generation I would
like to see a sequel to blood-borne to I
wanna get it I want to get a resistance
another resistance I know like be
truthful yeah I want another killzone in
the building I need that Mike Trapp
moment talk to me name change the
FairTax aphorism maybe sneak a horizon
horizon zero dawn to so like a little
peek in the future yeah the game
phenomenally well they don't have to
really change too much you know I think
that would be a my draft for me no don't
you want you want more quality what we
gonna get that's cool I'm kind of like J
bar I don't really do too much in the
hypotheticals man he got some good
suggestions um another game I would like
to see a sequel to that I actually think
people would be high for even though
people pretend not to like the first one
what to the order 1886
that world the world was created in uh I
might drive moment for me personally
this really not a mic drop is more like
an be like double with the mic and grab
another Sly Cooper game I will be very
high we need that but as far as stuff we
do know about listen man we are realist
here man we can't act like the last most
part to a friend
set the world ablaze call me the game
III I'm willing to guarantee you what
anybody will be told about me fire after
they see what their nails are so calm
really being real fanboy is with the
Sony language but really giving you
exactly what anticipation is so drop the
mic kill the game what tell you man like
mine isn't even really software-related
me to me is hardware
cleany drop drop the mic no no not even
that because they already made
statements around that I mean if they
did that that would be if they talked
about it and maybe show some trailers
that would be like what they did with
Killzone back in the day like that
Killzone trailer you that's that's still
wouldn't work out for today so I mean
today's today's game was a lot more
informed than I gonna have that that's
not gonna fly that's gonna be broken
down and destroyed on online so let's
not do that okay I would say don't get
me a vita 2.0 give me a new beautiful
wait wait wait super powerful Nobita 2.0
it plays all PlayStation 4 games I'm
gonna play playstation five games
autosave and a move
my trying to get inside if they could do
the cloud base that's really feasible
because I just have to say that Nintendo
Resident Evil that I just saw Resident
Evil 7 on the switch which I thought
would never ever be done it was Loki
impressive and it's in the fact that
they had it running on the Nvidia
hardware and if we're smart and we know
how Nvidia does they have the
cloud-based hub and all that stuff
already in place for that chipset and
that chip set is designed to take
advantage of cloud based gaming so you
saw it was a 1:1 ratio on the movement
so if Sony can do something in that
nature it's not far-fetched to say if
they can't have PlayStation 5 and
PlayStation 4 games and I tell you this
and I tell you this I a couple weeks
back there was a digital foundry video
that Richard Ledbetter did specifically
asking the question what if Sony did
that exactly that made a small portable
version of their PlayStation console and
to me and at the end at the end of the
video he basically said like he gave the
reasons why they wouldn't do it right I
don't why is Richard Ledbetter just out
of the blue gonna make a video about
that without any sort of knowledge of
anything down the pipeline and so it's a
very random video to make for no reason
when it when it smoke this fire I'm
telling you when you talk we've we
talked about all these consoles wanting
engagement above all else how do you
keep people playing on in your ecosystem
if you give me a portable play stance
you can tell me you can play god of war
while you at work I'm mad at me I'll
lose it I'm a little I'm really on let
me bring it back let me bring it back to
jak Bari and like if again I know we've
aided we beat a dreaming right now if
some type of announcement of them
getting back in the consoles I mean if a
handheld space like how would you feel
about that I feel good about it bro cuz
uh
I'll work two jobs you know maybe by the
end of the week
I mean it's right up my alley you know
me I mean Veta head voice chat point we
can offer if they can add on today you
know I'm all for don't want that because
I already have to fend these people off
[Music]
because I can't handle no more fanboys
but it's not it's not separate games
though attic what if it's just saying
games you could play at home when you
happen not to be home but you can just
ask continue what you were doing because
when the Remote Play feature came out
all like I mean yeah it wasn't perfect
but the fact and you know saying jump
into my ps4 and can experience you need
a Love & Hip Hop escape that's what I
was about to mention I was like the
things that you know we want when it
comes to the Vita could do but it does
the executions different that base if
not like it's locally on and the Vitas
this problem was like anything anything
they required both trigger buttons like
you know that back pad is horrible but
you say but Jack move like on the Vita
would get you excited if I know we
hoping and dreaming wishing on stars if
you heard about hey man I still own my
Vita come on up here I got a Vita TV I
wake up and like like Lord sovereign
just said the biggest issue with the
Vita is the fact that it did not have l
to win arches but also a 3 or 3 yeah I
needed a little kickable sticks yes if
they add those two things like I would
empower and just power up the Walloon
and improve either improve remote player
I have it to where you could play it
like well you wanna be out playing
natively but like yeah just a prude a
play or whatever hey man
I actually would like to see more to it
it really looks really good I would like
some software updates man like to be on
they got the games on law services and
hallway it's like why first off I want
to change my gamertag I have to okay
look some [ __ ] on Xbox took gaming
addict so that's not something I can do
on them but I'm pretty sure gaming
addict is available oh but you can't use
spaces so that's not made on you need to
just get up-to-date on software CD that
firmware of obviously you know
Microsoft's let's just not get into what
I want is I want them to and when it
comes to games I came to really think
anything either like maybe some
expansions on the city that I haven't
bought yet I mean maybe that I don't
know if Kingdom Hearts 3 is gonna be at
their show or not because Square Enix
has their own show Yoanna you just said
the Cydia yeah yo
come on home like I've been like law
they know how do you know you played the
city oh that's nice over my land with
the city that is my jam I'm not lost I
had all we need remake you know we make
up the original look trick star trick
I'm gonna have to get you man
unlike the I see commercial address
gamertag or PSA Robo Gordo
you'll solve a big king drop the mic
y'all which I need I already gave it to
you you gave me okay Dora I got you go
buy your boy your boy said it does 12
watch yourself with the snake oil listen
um let's go when he said to drop the mic
moment he didn't want you to come out of
state the four facts that we know what's
gonna beat it he wanted you to say what
will make you stand up and clap in chair
alright so you stole all my kill zone
you stole another shooter this solar is
it
so I will have to say a real game that
will make me stand up gonna and I'm a
fan of the system because of this game
Oh Jack and Dexter like I would really
open world I would my steena a Ratchet
and Clank sequel well I got Ratchet and
Clank you see this is what I'm saying I
got that and I'm content in there I love
the game feel a bit slow they would let
anyone take over the Jack and Dexter
brim but not hmm anyone else make that
brain no I don't think so
then again you know they let someone
else make Ratchet and Clank so the lathe
on my elf do on Charlie for Sony on a
piece when they can make a tail another
I don't know why I kind of feel like
Sony isn't going to be making moves like
that like I could see a Sly Cooper
before I see a jack indexer like to be
honest with you I'm a piggy back off
took a lot of guys I pink for me is I
think the only thing that Sony hasn't
done this Jen I mean they've dominated
they've had a defender phenomenal run
but I think they need to establish
something in that multi player space
that's their own that's not
[Applause]
Oh Lord and Lord addict the only thing
we care about that in that Sony
conference is the the destiny expansion
oh you know it was more so like I said
the multiplayer space that's exclusive
to them and I gonna oddly I think if
they are now so calming some fashion
just man I think that would be huge for
them like a gig that's something that I
don't know what's the history I could
school me on that you know I really
don't know what's going on with it but
if they would kind of reinvigorate it
even if like I said it is show gameplay
just to be honest with you people type
of genes II got a ps2
sorry mr. Bari mr. Baum hurry you let
somebody talk long enough they exposed
itself mr. Bari you playing on the PC
you doing what Microsoft intended you to
do what you just told me I would look
over there Oh mr. Barnow I'm going to
use Microsoft you know um slogan within
commercial you know you don't matter
feel me bad from 5:00 after you seen it
it's a games play best on xbox well I'm
a correct against playing purchases from
Microsoft and we appreciate your bus all
right get it to the floods I will have
LoJack boots set this off which is what
announcements are you hope are not made
that is a great question I have not
thought about that you know what would
piss me off because I do not like this
series but I like the other IP they
worked on if they announced a new kills
all game was coming out by Guerrilla
Games I would
have you spent waste time on that stage
talk about some more dreams I'm done
they said dreams it was that judges
weekend everybody came out of their say
is ridiculous
it's everything that LittleBigPlanet was
supposed to be whereas they came out it
they came out of Judge this week saying
the day's gone is not not dude too hot
so for all the vapor where the dreams
was apparently he came together all I
know is when I was at PS X and I seem
like thirty [ __ ] sitting on
beanbag chairs and they was watching
dreams and developer talk bro I just I
was I got hungry
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I heard I heard the game itself cuz you
know that that was the criticism with
LittleBigPlanet that the actual game
sucked like the the platforming was
floaty only the only thing good that
came out of is what people made so they
saying that the actual game is fantastic
and then in terms of the creation tools
is a lot easier intuitive to use you can
still use now this is the crazy thing
you can still you know use a regular
controller but
you can also use the Move controllers in
the camera as well so that's something
that promised way back so I mean
apparently it came together everybody
they talked about that I heard about
like you know Giant Bomb stuff like that
they're saying is great so I don't know
if we got to see we could we could
convince all day right now I don't know
if you did I mean it's a game is not as
much as I am advocate for VR if they
have like maybe your segmentation don't
gar I think point they could do that in
the in the pre-show and stuff like that
yeah that's a jump on jumpin on your
point is Coderre actually said they say
even though it's but if you are selling
well you said the growth the speed of
the market is lower than they predicted
so now they're gonna have a more
realistic outlook so one would hope you
didn't want to see hey yoki oh king king
want debate that's you bother you bought
that taken even two minutes five minutes
I don't want anybody on PlayStation
taking two minutes or five minutes at a
time
speaking on engagement I don't even want
them to talk about sales to be honest
like I don't I watch a conference to see
announcements and to see what their show
and not
to see how well they're doing I'm sorry
I know there's a good plane that that
tends to be you still want to do that
every year has spent at least ten
minutes talking about their cells we
know that to be honest - I don't know I
don't even want to see a like update
announcement on the show like you can do
that in a brief show and all that stuff
I'll be corny if they do that it show do
that in the pre-show because my name is
xbox 360 level he wants to change to
xbox why he complained about multiplayer
[Laughter]
let's get it to the Lord
so anybody could jump from the Lord's
first what do we need to see I don't
want to see engagement numbers I don't
want I don't want them to talk about the
the VR headset itself I don't want them
to talk about the call of duty
engagement deals they have I don't want
to talk didn't talk about any kind of
marketing deals I just want to see the K
you say they go adults do channels for
the PlayStation view I'm dead but you
don't want to see man I don't you know
another thing I don't want to see
another whack ass TV show coming on
their service either loose I don't want
them to announce name changes because I
just want to see people pissed off
okay come on be like nice never happened
and we tried it never happened a robbery
like didn't in the last what I think was
Greg Miller had asked one of the Sony
execs and he's so late and says yeah he
said it's come he said he said something
to the effect like you probably won't be
asking me this question to get next year
right we get the fob that it's actually
coming right hopefully that's the
biggest thing I don't want in this in
this III is that like the PSX I'm set up
I don't want that I don't want no cheers
hello just don't they're gonna start a
Call of Duty this show twenty minutes of
one of those four games show another
third because people keep forgetting
they start third party marketing goes
like they're going at e3 time this is
going to show another third party
Margaritaville and then they're going to
show another twenty minutes to something
that another one of those games like
that's literally what's gonna happen I
think a day now something it's gonna be
at the very end when they close the show
maybe be like a days oh yeah you don't
think this is a blast of us for like to
drop it I think they're closing if
anybody remembers what was last year's
opening for the Sony legacy I think
they're about to say I'm Tony Jack go
fishing Sigma yeah he said he said he
think in my open would goes to SEMA and
close the last of us to know that's
possible to that's kind of hard
mmm the money says supposed to be the
open with spider-man let me get King in
and I'll wrap this one up on that topic
King with you but you don't want them I
don't want them to put a logo up I don't
want them to talk nothing
I want them to give these people false
hope and you know take away the
attention from what they're doing now
let's be honest you know it was the long
crawl back in to reach this level of
success from that was the PlayStation 3
that's fantastic and I can understand
why they pound in a chest not a feeling
good because he was feeling bad for so
long that now is your time and you're
supposed to have that sunshine on you
it's good but remember I told you what
you said you don't want to see no chance
up your snow being bad yeah you don't
must see people eating fool like you
know we made it you know we made it yeah
cuz then you know what happens right
after that part right I really feel that
I just I just want them to bask in a
moment so I don't want to see no
PlayStation Father agree I definitely
agree with the Alan thing we ready sir
I don't think I'm not going to see no
new console yet there's still a lot
coming Pia for I don't think they need
to show that I honestly believe that I
think they're trying to push us forward
to these new systems for no reason when
um these systems gotta be maximized like
you remember when y'all saw Donkey Kong
or Nintendo like oh you thought it was
over to use a hold up wait a minute like
I want that feeling I want them to push
it forward I don't think that they did
they're striving for that yet Factory I
think a little Jack can take over right
now let me read the message property yo
Jeff are we you and Jack and take over
the show I tell King to chill I
so let me tell you what's gonna really
happen now I don't know what happened to
close-ups
let's get the clothes out because we're
already over time anyway so let's get
these outros going and so guys thank you
so much for coming through today
PlayStation nation in the building with
the iron Lords at the roundtable big
shout out to all day digital Jay Bari
Jack moves on you guys we knew it was
gonna be fired today we knew already
know man
so guys yeah guys one at a time just go
out let us know what you're doing give
us till your stuff people do what you
could do what you do alright uh
appreciate y'all having me oh man hey
y'all hey you know K what smoke back
appreciate that I can always appreciate
that uh sad the cradle see couldn't make
it
what I got going on check now on the
weapon wheel podcast today man y'all
know where to find that just type in
weapon we apply a cast check now and
pressed our podcast on Thursdays on Kofi
channel and uh YouTube in a Twitter man
Jack Moore Johnny appreciate y'all yo yo
yeah uh thanks for having me appreciate
invite Mitch it was fun he was like good
discussion yeah I mean y'all can find me
on Twitter all day underscore digital
man alright so quick real quick [ __ ]
send the message out he wants one last
question for everybody before we go I
said what are you guys thinking on PS 5
release date when do you think they're
gonna talk about it
when do you think it's coming up cuz
everybody they've already they put it
out there that the plea is for is life
cycle is ending right and everybody's
just jumps to conclusions about when
that is and then we're like okay it's
three years out so when do you think we
get some sort of announcement something
concrete where they
to actually talk about what this machine
is III 2019 they'll drop in 2020 I mean
I'm in agreeance with that yeah I think
we're gonna get the announcement in 2020
it's possible you can come out 2020 fall
or it might be 2021 if you guys you guys
see more for more of a fall release or
are you guys looking because I mean the
switch proved that you can release
something you believe hardware March and
still be successful yeah I'm gonna go
fall when it comes to places go they run
a different yeah this stuff is way
different
I think Nintendo had to act outside the
box because of the the failure of the
arm the Wii U so a lot of stuff they
were doing on the fly and they didn't
anticipate NVIDIA having all those
chipsets ready to go in the screen so
everything was ready to go so they were
in a position to launch an attack at
that place you know so I think it worked
well for Nintendo I don't think it works
well for Microsoft or Sony in that space
so I think yeah I think it announced
next year PSX
next show so end of 2019 yeah definitely
either that or early already 2024
release they have their own event before
e3 and they show PS 5 exclusive PS 5
launch titles III next year are you guys
ready for it I don't care
2020 is good for me like I took me I
honestly like wait what they started to
do with the with the iterative consoles
and stuff with the pro and like you know
there is an X I don't not to write on
anyone's parade when he left you only
have a certain amount of time before my
back
real quick before this joint cut out
again is as far as like what I don't
want to do we finish up that yeah the
script exactly to what they said like I
did I would like some level of surprise
that was all that pretty much I wasn't
getting it so we up to the last joint
now yeah why we we did outros we scouted
adult roles and then the question came
in late so these guys did the out roads
we haven't done ours yet again even
though they did them real shout out to
Jack child all day digital you know say
come to last minute J bar II with the he
here's a big y'all for coming through
much appreciated
I want to say that personally because I
was in love and get so need a building
represented you already know and of
course I helped ease in the building
Lord addict where can I find people find
you those wicked people find you what
else you got cooking up you can find me
on YouTube gaming addict Twitter
actually I'm gonna launch my Twitter in
the actual chat be sure to follow me on
Twitter I be tweeting some dumb [ __ ] but
it's it's a nice little thing I'm
actually starting a stream on make sure
some I don't know how long that's gonna
last because make sure kind of I don't
know I don't know if I make sure it's
the lab it would definitely be sure to
check out our guests you know they're
all good content creators plug deep and
think if he could get they plug on yeah
don't no doubt good good good no cool
north south waking the fire people find
you you can find me on
Lord stop ILP on PSN and Xbox Live but
they say what he does put out chip with
its quality premium premium yeah you can
catch me on PSN and xbox live at a biack
sovereign and guys um big shout out to
everybody who supported us in that
patreon it's still going strong picks
out next week is gonna be our first
official week we're giving out prizes
and big and shout outs to everybody
supporting us on patreon guys if you're
listening right now if you want to
support us so you want to see us grow
see us get better if you if you like
what we do you want to see it get better
head on over to that patreon and give it
a look really greatly appreciated so
it's um patreon.com slash iron Lords
podcast
um again next week is gonna be our first
official week giving out our prizes and
whatnot so thank you thank you for just
being here every Sunday we appreciate
y'all absolutely Lord King with all type
of smoke goes to cradle are you gonna
say you will come on the podcast to give
King that smoke but you know you gotta
be a graduation shout-out to G bar I
[Laughter]
gotta beat you I heard about you before
even got in here and I really on the
safe side you should probably return
that freezer t-shirts t-shirts will be
announced next week for you to have your
III t-shirt so you could represent
combat talk with the king is coming to
the iron Lords channel with because
while I'm on telly I'm going to the wild
card studio and getting the interview
with I'm going understand 60s ol it when
I'm out there - um I just want y'all to
understand that we really appreciate all
the time and all engagement
you guys have rocked through this whole
show and I really want to take my hat
off to you guys in that chat because
every five seconds I gotta keep looking
and it's a big I gotta figure out who
said what to get to what to who it's so
fantastic I love you guys I love
everybody was on this show
I anticipated this show so much when I
saw who was coming on and you know like
I said oh we got stuck on stupid you
know when you're coming through we want
to get him on a show for so long you
finish whatever you having me on floor
press start and the crew I know you did
to shout out and of course G bar with
the smoke the movie made himself I know
you got the council going on please
check out his channel old I figured I
had to said you want to get you in a
show form back next week no doubt the
Luca and also with Jack well press Start
we had coffee last week whatever so on
yeah next week is the Microsoft showed
closed the series out and then obviously
on a games like yelling to that oh you
know this is go
now which is it well we keep we keep it
under it'll be pretty epic let's just
say it's gonna be pretty epic I can be
very impressive what we got going again
crazy crazy guys like that like this way
[Music]
I want you to really see a real show
when I go down Microsoft better bring it
I don't want me to bring Jack move back
again patreon supporters I know we just
started in like the response is just
humbling like just to see everybody come
in a few days that was absolutely love
again King already mentioned we got
combat talk coming up on the IOP channel
and also we're gonna get back into the
flash points with the bounces shout out
to him we're gonna get that going you
know Lord carboxyls gonna get the audio
and the time stands up later on tonight
everybody please enjoy your evening
having a good time and all that good
stuff and everybody I go cut you
internet out like me do
[Laughter]